and also the ohms lote portal My name is
Lucas Carneiro and I spoke a little about
biology as data science
Starting with what bioinformatics is the
development, implementation and use of
methods and software tools to
understand biological data
bioinformatics has its
practical applications  in the area of ​​health in agriculture
and in the mitigation of climate
change as this field France Av
informatics presents several challenges
both for students trying to learn
there and for teachers trying to
teach
and in this presentation are the current challenges and
limitations of bioinformatics  and I will
describe how we face these
challenges with a single batch program,
we will also talk about Bloom's taxonomy and
how it is applied in the
computer courses on our portal.
projects and finally
would take some results of the ecological program
well then what are some of the Challenges
that bioinformatics currently faces
to start this field is in
constant growth either due to the
development of new technologies and
new software to improve the time and
power of data processing the
analyzed data are usually in
large amounts What consumes  a lot of
memory and processing mainly
on personal computers despite
being publicly available there is
a certain complexity to access
this data where usually
programming knowledge is necessary
for this the same way uplines and
analysis programs require knowledge
in programming that many biologists do not
have.
about the
University environment students gain
theoretical knowledge but do not receive
practical experience with full work juice
mainly due to
previous limitations
talking about faculty these already
face challenges to cover a range
of diverse topics s  and if you are specialized
in some area of ​​Informatics or if you
are not familiar with
bioinformatics in general, for example, the
professor who researches the expression of
oncogenes and may not know much about the
genomic goal of seawater
is precisely with the intention of overcoming
these challenges  the
unixlog platform was developed this program
aims at bioinformatics SOS which
translated means to standardize organize and
systematize training in
bioinformatics to make these
analyzes useful for any biologist or
clinician is because we see the need for
standardization
mainly to keep the content up to
date since  these courses
are usually developed at home and
taught sporadically the
organization is already necessary because the
combination of several different topics
is A Challenge through it we
manage to maintain the flow and
transitions of the content already the
systematization is important to evaluate
but the progress of the people  how to give
more attention  o to students who are having
difficulty or also open to people
who are already one step ahead of the
logical UNIP uses standardized modules and
interactive pressures starting the
condo of keywords
terminologies and concepts soon we
implement a set of real data
and use a based approach  on
projects and
how is this learning process good
to guide them in
the skills development process
batch men employ
bloom's taxonomy learning levels this approach
starts with the basics students remember
all terminology facts and are
able to  repeating and memorizing the
material with this base learning
builds
conceptual knowledge i.e. being able to understand
the concepts and apply the information and
new situations and later the student
will be able to analyze the lips create
connections and then evaluate using a
given the meters it takes  at the
highest levels of learning will be the
ability to design and create  er original works
and as resources of the single Lógico that
help to advance in the teaching of
informatics some Lógico that has the
portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics in it you will
find courses designed to take
theoretical knowledge
training modules data analysis tool
sets of  data from
selected projects and interactive sessions with
mentors to provide the student with a clear
path in the taxonomy pyramid
again so no matter what
the user's initial experience as
had been informed uniform is a
useful tool to gain knowledge
of the theory behind bioinformatics
to  analyze large datasets
to introduce programming languages ​​such
as Python or to
start a data analysis project
from scratch
16 courses are taken from
the uniflor core curriculum available an alarm
starting with an introduction to
applications bless magic and an
overview  of data types the alu  in is able
to learn terminology and
factual knowledge from there are introduced
genomics transcriptomics meta genomics
epigenetics and data science each
course starts with important terms and concepts
and then presents
case study and to Pillars
related to each And this allows students
to  students acquire
conceptual knowledge to start their own
projects
and what the project is for we know
that the best way to learn about the
content is through the application of the
content for example a case study
on our platform we have
real case studies that were  prepared by
our network of mentors and collaborators
that illustrate how various
informatics methods and numerical data types
are used in current research in
medicine for example oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience biotechnology
agriculture and even astrobiology
projects are prepared with
publicly available data and use a to
explore understand  er challenge of research
as well as the path of analysis in this
way we will be able to extract
significant insights in the most
complex
human data the ohms lot platform offers
students options to analyze a
given
set of data this data set can be used in
several ways you can learn
bioinformatics  without any qualifications
Paraíso in each project we explain the
pillars of analysis on the platform teme
Olimpo a friendly platform for
analysis and data but had you
can also learn the scripts because of the
steps learn to organize clean
visualize and analyze data and
popular programming languages ​​like r and  Python
and from there create your own
analyzes finally you can also
hear about research projects and applications
in Our programs guided
by mentors by experts who
share their experiences and support
research projects developed by
you
and here are examples from the online Park  and
independent of the code the
platform interface had eight is a color
-coded partline in its help to
establish a logical connection between the
technical names and the logical steps
necessary to build your
particular in complete the
preferred data with the input file and in
then the analyzes can be chosen
Based on the title needs each part of the
analysis separated into 3 colors blue for
pre-processing red for
mapping and green for Purification
when you click a button the total
for more additional information useful
for building the parent has the  ease
of color-coded buttons
allows programs to be run without
any decoding knowledge
and after using the platform asked to
view parents online and practice
analysis students can take their
theoretical knowledge remember and understand
the levels of there are you missing it  me and
apply some original project
likewise the faculty must be ca  peace of
assigned the program loidy men
sometimes some with the understanding of Chris
Brown comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics another objective of the project
is that students are able to read and
understand the primary literature to
recreate methodologies in that led them the
ability to find errors and
solve  issues
and the single batch program employs a
hybrid approach combining learning and
research to ensure eggs
are developing at the first level
of Bloom's taxonomy the single chick
tracks progress with activities such
as private programming
literature review quiz on Top
Key Terms and also covers  a wide range
of topics such as biomedical research,
biotechnology and agriculture and so
students can in addition to showing that they
understand the literature continuing
their knowledge base such as
evaluating research making sure they are
able to understand the methods, challenges
and outcomes it must also be  able
to ask questions based on the
exploration of that data
In a nutshell bioinformatics combines
biology terms with
data science skills which enables
researchers to
answer life science questions with
reproducible data analysis method
and investigator members or
known as their files download
can ask research questions on
any computer topic leading to
a diverse range of projects from the
analysis of biological pathways affected in
multiple sclerosis
from brain metastases from viral
to small cell lung cancer these students can
apply what  learned on the course to
work with the professional debentures group
and submit their projects
on the portal for review students should
then be able to reach the
highest level of Bloom's taxonomy create
This is achieved by creating
your own analysis project for
example top  of reading a student of
scientific initiation at the Univ  Basic education is
good why did you finish your
training in research the only one or
working on a project involving
chronic lymphocytic leukemia a type
of blood cancer that has a biological background a
lot have the genius in various
treatment strategies using data And
like me  knew and from healthy people she was
able to analyze that most
genes are involved in biogenesis and
RNA processing
as a result 33 non-coding RNA
without long pores differentially
expressed and saw that there were
differences in the expression of these is real
as cancer progresses and when it tires  he
was in spontaneous relationship
is an example at the end of the
learning outcome of the program.
who is Involved with the
project and mentor him to Bros Dr
Henrique and the doctor cause as well as
our  University of
Ghana collaborators Doctor Anitta and Doctor Benedita
this post was about a
critical interaction in pneu mano red blood cells
several candidates have been studied
with varying success in
glass stages and early clinical trials in this
force We share
preliminary findings that suggest these
genomic data  can be used to
develop in the local strategy for an
effective vaccine project against the
infection in blood state as
much as in the neighboring regions the
only logic is sought decoration
diverse programs around the world for
example the husband of the National Association
of india the  main ideas we also
work with over 15,000 students and
community colleges a community college
in Greenville we have
can also be today a top university
like George University as
well as 20 other Universities
worldwide EA with Total satisfaction I give you
the  welcome to the portal
dental